bien basse au blender et pour arbitrer
lenten j'appelle ma chair vive clarté
kelly santé
wu
m
quand il va m'aider à arbitrer semble en
fait ça va ça va très bien vous verrez
c'est le principe quand on est des
morceaux est ce qu'on veut c'est
entendre le nom de l'interprète est pas
le titre du morceau aujourd'hui
puisqu'on se blondasse les poupées
contre les palettes à maquillage mais
barbie bien
bravo l'ont bâti
michaud
non
il va
damien natalia tania soufflage ya collé
à la fois je vais répéter bêtement une
connerie doit d'ailleurs beaucoup du
mail pour vous ah oui votre numéro de
portable surtout les gens veulent votre
numéro de portable derrière la brigade
et didier l'interpellent
si barak mais s'il ya bien entendu c'est
tout le point situé au centre est hyper
concentré 1 c'est que des blondes
décolorées c'est un indice comme didier
c
dans ce cas ne soit pas si bête bien
britney il est bon moment
bien didier
je vous reconnais je reconnais que c'est
pénible de jouer j'ai fait d'études la
madrague à la 3ème note évidemment il
est génial métro
vous avez le vis comme une blonde higway
à
après la mairie toi tu couches avec ma
femme ou voix oui mais ça rien à voir
les quiz
elle ne donne pas les quiz à mort je ne
crois pas à ça surtout chez elle on
revient pas tekken monaco tandis que les
conneries
bon allez
j'y allais
tu as sauvé l'honneur
de toute manière il ya des couplages la
clé qu'est ce que c'est fou ce souffle
h&m soufflage la docteur dion attend
oui
non
alors
m
le cheval a retrouvé geri halliwell on
passe la tension ce soir c'est très
important
y'a banco et super banco di palo gym
allons y à beaucoup et super banco donc
ceux qui trouvent le manque hogan et ce
qui après tout le chicago regarde mais
cgt voit c'est encore plus injuste que
d'habitude
ah oui
aulas
la semaine
m
les
je tenais à l' indice comme julien elle
a épousé un vieillard qu'elle évolue ça
ne vient rien
mais tu es une star ce soir c'est de
france saf et deux choristes arabe
félicitations donc maintenant messieurs
le super banco va départager les deux
équipes le score est de 6 pour les
poupées et de 3 pour les galettes des
paillotes
voilà donc super banco didier
bon
ben de londres
voilà mesdames messieurs c'était tout
moment par l'émission paca